comme nous on n'a pas de papiers j'ai
deux enfants et on y va pour faire les
courses et me marier comme il travaille
pas on a besoin de faire les courses
[Musique]
sommes sur un choeur chante césure donc
forcément j'ai envie de travailler et
dans des endroits comme ça où il ya
énormément de monde
on est actif et moi ça me fait vraiment
plaisir de pouvoir aider les gens
dans le besoin comme ça donc je préfère
donner mon temps à sa carrière chez moi
[Musique]
oh
tous
[Musique]
bien sûr je suis inquiet parce que nous
rentrons dans une crise économique
et cette crise là elle va les
foudroyante et aussi que la précarité
elle va pas s'arrêter elle va
d'augmenter segmenté de plus en plus
[Musique]
bon